a few days ago i was
probably the biggest one day event in
the world the super bowl and that's
why because all of germany
and all of europe is also about football i
was curious and wanted to go there and
lo and behold the nfl football league in the usa
is coming to germany now too
soon there will be a game in
germany there is a head of the nfl
in germany who will
attack the bundesliga in the end he wants to
ensure that football is no longer just the
second class already the
second most important german sport
but becomes the most important and who that
is how we do that
the german nfl boss alexander
stein is
about to explain that the month before she was 9 so i'm
really excited is how can you be
thanks for the invitation you make a
huge show when the passport is
issued is born on the day we also
take two days on friday  before
how were you born is
so officially i haven't
been around that long i le  last week tuesday
first day but had the chance to work a bit behind the
scenes in the last few weeks and months
how did i get there
have spent the last few years in sport
brought one or the other station behind
me,
starting with manunited then in the
bundesliga  switched to fortuna
fortuna düsseldorf spent time at dfl
a bit in parallel and now
most recently the olympic environment at the marketing agency of the
german
olympic sports federation and now at the
nfl and waterworks over right
started with advice then
relaxed and then at the sports ground okay okay that
means digital business  goes familiar and
sport that's also familiar i would
now say yes i my
people like you hide us of course
even deeper in digital knowledge is in it
but at least i
spent a bit of time there because we
need some significant
ventures so i was  that's it  ch
already more than ten years ago so came
back classic actually
done advice back then after two years
in berlin changed to lure and went
to wimdu back then i don’t know
who
was relatively well financed at the time
and i came in after
it was actually clear that it wasn’t  to
erwin how to sell that was of
course also the bet back then and when an
attempt was made
to
transform or further develop a sustainable business model
i then got involved and
then did online marketing & marketing as
a whole and yes exactly back then
exactly in 2013 i was something  I think I've
come back now for the listeners, an
anecdote from back then I had relatively
little to do with him because I
think he always focuses on
the business models where he
thinks he can sell them,
so in that respect there are no major
overlaps with him personally
I also had a
bit of anek back then  doten still heard from
the phase when it was supposed to be sold,
when somehow erwin's people were
like over there and the office was
filled up again
so you had lots then didn't have much
to do with him but rather
just a little bit  so being able to
soak up this local spirit was
still a lot of fun
was a super instructive time because yes,
as they say, you go from
zero to a hundred quickly, you were
n’t too deeply involved in topics beforehand
and so and so the samba the nfl boss
already met roger waters i've
already got to know him i've been able to get to know him so
nice comparison isn't 100%
accurate is yes
but yes had had several video
crosses with which we might
probably come back to what is
now pending in germany had
now on  wednesday a press conference
with him when he announced where
games will be held in germany soon
and exactly in that respect  ever had the
opportunity to say with him
and i should be germany
managing director germany ceo what
does day-to-day business actually
mean you are asked here to say that
yes it is a very exciting role
because i am now the first person to
do it  permanently employed in germany
it's now a lot about building
things up because in the last few
years i think the nfl has had really impressive growth rates in germany in terms of
tv
reach what consumer projects etc are
concerned but that was all controlled
from london above all  things from the usa
and now it's just about
doing exactly that from germany and
then reaching the next level again,
i.e. all the topics that concern us
, which we believe also work in
germany and continue to do so locally  to drive ok
but then how did you not get
there so it's not like that
I can apply but
at some point no one came looking for someone
there weren’t those who called
yes I think you can sum it up like this
usually sport is
another special branch
because the branch is actually relatively
small and like I said  Most of the
positions are not
advertised publicly. I
just now we've already talked about it. I've
had a couple of positions in sports. I hope I've done a
really good job there
because the person who spoke to
me knew that I hadn’t
been in my role that long, so
I looked at hellkuhl,
that would interest me myself, yes
, I can go in for the talks, ok, and
tell me what’s going on, that says yes,
look  the nfl in germany
we're actually already talking about governing
somehow  he before the
second largest sport is the factor in
germany after football i think it
always depends on
which angle you look at it from if
you are about active sports
then it clearly corresponds to the
tone in germany which i
didn’t know before either  i think five
six million members it is
the sport with the most members after football
active sausages with american football will
not reach number 2 in the next few years
although there is really strong
growth one of the
strongest growing sports active
series but at a relatively
low level  level started but with the
other things that we look at yes
so what does tv reach do what
does merchandising do right now e.g. what
reaches do you also generate
digitally we are in some points already
either number 2 or so in
any case the goal is that we  point
us in the direction of development over the next few years  n he was
such a day only had 40 hours that
means if the nfl gets more attention
then we have to give others
attention that means if
i now call you the gravedigger of the
german handball bundesliga, the
german basketball bundesliga and the
german ice hockey bundesliga
, that is it  like a compliment or then
i would deny it lastingly yes
it is so it is also very clearly
explained writing has is also such an
ornament or so our our approach is it
not now to become more active in
germany and somehow always
take something away yes you have  right the day
only has 24 hours but in the end
you are also competing with a netflix with a
spotify with good podcast and i think
that is not the case that you can only
follow one sport yes but you are
as we can see with the people  who
have become nfl fans in germany in recent years
usually
have other sports that they also
follow  gen know i found it very exciting
at the press conference that the
dfl sees you as a partner i would have
said at least from a dfl perspective
i would be donata hops i would
have said the nfl is more of
a danger for me and
i don’t support that like you  you
kind of made friends with the
dfl so first of all you have to
realize that when you watch an nfl game in
germany it's an extremely
complex process to set something up
it's not just about logistics
it was all of a sudden  you're not talking about eleven
players but about a total of 120
players post plus coffee tea
but just the game plan as far as
cook is concerned cook is betting on 20 22 23 24 25
and you know that the window in
which you can organize games at all is simply extremely small
because every
federal league has to have stadiums
basically being kept available on matchdays for the
bundesliga, which means
we also need a very, very close
exchange  ch with the dfl and the exchange
existed before that
it is clear to me now that you think it's good but the
enemy in my bed I understand
myself of course dfl is good so of the way
under christian seifert also
already a good exchange and now
exactly  in the process where we became
more specific with those with
the cities, we also entered into a
close exchange with the dvl,
because if there is a question to be
spoken to in the end, in the end it is so that
my view of it is actually
different  or there are interests that are of
course different on the two sides
but that complement each other extremely well because as the nfl
we as the nfl the first step to
germany or the first big steps
game is
clear they noticed that was
announced again today
and now in the  tal came out there is
now one nfl game a year in
germany, in frankfurt and in
munich the first münche  n now
somehow in this year of a year
that's also really big news we're
talking about a business cases
hannover are talking about 30 40 million
and that makes up a game exactly you
can maybe go back
a point right away why does the dfl let itself
be on a  partnership with you
one of them could also say i
prefer to keep the nfl out of germany
because frankly i as dfl
would rather have the one-eyed national
handball league ice hockey and
basketball league as competitors than the
nfl because this is better than me
so in the end  it's a question that
probably had to be asked by the dvl
but i'm saying from my point of view and i
also have something to do in the
internationalization commission of the
dfl and
i was allowed to join the discussion about exactly these topics the
dfl and german football as a whole topic
growth where can you  of course, growing has
its own interests, for
example, making even greater use of the usa as a large market
and  if
you then think about who you are
working with or with whom it makes sense to
cooperate, then you look at the
usa and it is by far the nfl's
biggest strongest league strongest brand so when
we talk about partnership with
the dfl it's fine  that's exactly why
you chose it yourself so you ask what gives you like what they give you it's clear let it happen
stalin row your schedule in but what gives what
does the dfl specifically so that's exactly
the question we'll be answering now in the next few
weeks months  and
i think it even says in the
press release
that we will set up
working groups with the dfl in march/april
to answer exactly these
questions how can
this cooperation actually be deepened because if
it is about reach if it is about tv contacts
if it is about  there are these topics, the
dfl has a lot of interest in the usa and of course we also have a lot of topics related to the design of fixtures
other topics of course the interest
not as invaders he has the
superstitious sports landscape to come
but to be close together alex your
answer is so to speak an
american media professional never
acceptance of the question but now
you were at you were at
fortuna so  a customer a short
football digression yes so if you had to invest all your
saved assets
on the premier league and the
bundesliga now don’t just say something like
that or but now premier league
or bundesliga his assets
give me a few minutes
before we get to such a strong German topic
einstein comprehensive school
is super bowl is talking a bit about the
business case symbol is not up
to us in the preparation to ask if
the ball is really some kind of
unicorn if you can
actually make a billion in sales here on sunday that day the time
has come  we that
at all probably but
guess that if i end up being there
Do you watch it of course others or
which revenue streams will you
look at and I think if you just gather
information that is
publicly available yes if you
look, for example, what does a tv
station do with advertising this year in the
superbike there are 450 million
dollars the  nbc about the spots
reinhold look at eticketing there the
prices were also played quite a
lot in the media that you can
add up the next one advertising sponsoring what is added you
probably come close to the billion
so just based on the
publicly available
information you would have to think  i'm not
far from that which is
interesting because the whole discussion from
germany also the bundesliga is a
completely different one there is never the high
ticket prices is here simply
would be accepted without complaint that yes in
germany never is amazing
what you can say texts apple 1000
euro as cheap t  icket i still
think it's exactly i think this year it's
about the cheapest ticket in the region
i think it's a completely
different to a completely different history of
german sport us sport is clear it
's business it's also about
making money what yes  in germany it is
at least more and more difficult to
argue and to position the whole
thing like
that, but it would also be in the usa and
you notice that if you promise it
as a once-in-a-lifetime
story yes you are
not talking about a season ticket here
you buy it again every year, but if
your club makes it into the superbowl
then you try to get there
somehow and yes there are also many
people who are willing to pay a lot of money
for the fact that you say all new england
patriots fans are actually now
insolvent  because they somehow had a 10
once in a lifetime chance in the last
five years
they definitely had a lot of luck and a
lot of success in  the last few years and
had so there is such a demand
for the game that we are now also seeing
in germany that far exceeds
the ticket the available tickets
so even if you say want
its lifetime story not everyone can
make it at all there probably wanted to
announce it  actually today that
machines sucher and oem he would take over the
ticketing business for the nfl game in
munich yes
and that wasn't agreed
the podcasts for it would be really cool because the
ticketing didn't go well so
there's the information that somehow it fits
into the stadium  how many people purely
manually playful what is that 60,000
80,000 yes so you have to take out a few seats
to make it nfl ready
but who has between 60 and 70 make
you could sell so we have
switched to a page where you
can register your interest if you have it now
would like the is although we have in good
server collapsed right at the
beginning we are j  now after
two days with a quarter of a million
ticket requests and ticket colleagues to
say it again, on average
a fan orders three tickets that means you
already have a de facto feeling for
half a million tickets that would be in demand
if you so how exactly if  you take
the three as a basis then even 750 because
you have so many link newcomer in friends
now i have i have many many
new linkedin joy but actually
also quite exciting many of whom i
didn't even know who wrote to
me hey i've been a grown-up for years
football fan and when are the
tickets available and how can you get in that
's something yes if you
look at the football from the outside you
always hear from a circle of friends how
many people there
may have been enthusiastic about in recent years
but  actually heard from a lot of
people where I didn't even know who
said if I stay up on Sunday evenings
or stay up late and the
sp  a lot to look at how do i
tick how many germans brought in
so what is what can you do that so governs
about that there are at the st there are two
proseves how maybe are as well as his
last year it was over two
million and you have to
keep in mind that of course it's only time
when you otherwise never arrive at such values
think the ratin
s market share is over 80% investment me not s
re but in the last
ew years I also think from a few years
it was still a million and that
is roughly the growth rate that i had in
germany and now
i can't say that so he can say a lot
about himself i can say that
you have now this year at the super bowl
he nl copied a bit the
open-air festival within the  in the
halftime show also relies on all these
hip hop stars or so to speak
the jaycee the film is best my circumstances
because
they
think so i can say that  well, in the end
that was over i think even if we
talk about what makes american football
special what makes it special i think there is
this very close connection between
sport and entertainment and you are
right, at least to me it might still be the case in
a few other sports
a little bit into trend sports
or yes, the whole red bull story
never like that, they are close to each other
but when we look at the classic big
sports in germany there
is always a critical view when you
look at helene fischer somehow at half
time and stuff like that  further
there is afterwards the shitstorm
there was and here it is such a
highlight that everyone is looking forward to and
also a very under or
low-threshold entry into the sport
if you hear around in your circle of friends there
are also many who say hey
maybe even  didn't
understand all the rules but i know now that dr
dre snoop dogg occur at halftime
that  i don't want to miss it
and that you can actually see that here
in all areas we can
actively go into sales again right away
how closely this is related and
especially in which he of course now
the perfect location we will be the
warmest super bowl i think in
history  27 degrees
monster stadium and is of course now
great for you also for the nfl that
now the factor with the chargers
and the rems two teams are back in the
ley and rihms are also in the super
bowl yes so next year
phoenix arizona can be there  it's even warmer
i've also heard from people who have been there for
20 years it's never been like this
at the superbowl in february you're
absolutely right this is actually
the ideal location if you want to
embody or bring to life exactly
what the nfl is all about  this
connection between entertainment and
sport i was at
an awards ceremony yesterday as the mvp of the
season w  medal is when
you usually get awards in
sport he always has or
has a bit of a
dusty
feeling. awards were given yesterday by katy perry
from kelly clarkson et cetera
yes you can see they are close
together and here with  the location
suits everyone living next door is the way now
tried with the german player so
, for example, there will also be a first half
show in munich in the first
game something like that would make sense a yes
that's not all right now in
detail he defines it with wrong  or
if we look at england, for example
, there have been
international games of the nfl since 2007,
there is also such a thing that there is music
act in the halter that of course fits
together extremely well and
then it’s about okay how do you try that
to position in germany
and in the end yes a bit
probably the middle way that
we try this all amer on the one hand  ican
experience really these stars and
stripes and what people
see on the tv but of course
also with a german touch
similar to london that's the way
to bring it to germany i think
in the allianz arena
sarah connor can still die  sing the national anthem
or
yes i remember it but i
think that now exceeds my
paygate that no but of course
we know how do you want to do the game in
germany somehow now
what are you still negotiating
with television stations or support
partners is all that  already clarified so
the
television contracts are still running
with version and with the prosiebensat 1
group they have the rights at the moment
and they will also broadcast the
game for Germany accordingly in the
end it is like this we have been
under water extremely short in the last few weeks
exhausting process that made
this selection cities have
bewo  But not just cities, but
the corresponding football clubs, the
federal
states, the stadium operators, and over the last few weeks and months we have been looking
at which packages fit best and now we know where we
are playing, but in what form, yes, like you,
for example, in the topic  entertainment
what is the subject of telegate
it's so American things that
you actually only
come there three hours beforehand i have to say the value
düsseldorf with the fairground spaces was
much better in
munich they have the multi-storey car park and in such a multi-storey car park
making telegate is really not good
it came off in munich that's the question
frankfurt because of the airport or if
the damage is bigger or yes you see
düsseldorf eggs the third city that was
still in the selection and when i got the
you there i have of course also
I had a lot of sympathy, but in the
end it was about getting the best
overall package and playing there
completely different factors
on the one hand of course how does the
business case look like can you
afford it economically and does it make
sense to do it in the context
it's about questions like how many places are
there for hospitality gc then it's
about how the  infrastructure connection
airport et cetera were you just
saying how many hotels are there in the
city or the club is
asked to make training grounds
available all of these things
looked at us and in the end of course we also saw
what the city is on fire for example is
that a radiance that then  also
plays back on the nfl all the
things taken together
didn't give this clear picture
but we said hey munich and
frankfurt am both extremely
tried hard and gave an extremely strong picture
and so is then to this alternative
or heart to this  220 cdi coach
came that's a shame I have to
say yes I would of course  just like
you were for düsseldorf and
rhein fire it was already a
really big success back then yes well frankfurt
galaxy and rhein fire i think i think
the two locations back then
you just mentioned the right but
you said yes the son
and we still have prosiebensat 1  for
the next season the rights and after that
when the newly advertised so exactly
the contracts are still running you are of
course always watching anyway how
can you
optimize the media product further develop I think
everyone who has now followed american football in the
last few years has also
seen and knows  that
our media partners also have an extremely
large share in what has happened in the
last few years, because in the
end you have to be honest if
you rewind five, six, seven years
in football today
, the nfl already has it in Germany
rather had a niche existence and together
with the media partners with the
posit  ionization of the products is just that
in the last few years, which means that in
the end prosieben created a lot of value for you
because prosieben were the ones
who took the hand
with us and the nfl that, so to speak, the personal
coach is really to pull it up
can you say yes, well, they have a
very large part in it, yes, not only
prosieben sat1 people would also be
partnerships with bild et cetera, for
example, java content is distributed in
the end is the question and everyone would certainly ask
themselves every
sport that tries it now  getting new or
stronger into the market how
do you do it how do you do that in a
country that is of course historically extremely
shaped by football like germany and
mentions this different way of addressing the coach summe and at the beginning
and frank buschmann they obviously have an
extremely large share  because that's
what happened in the last few years
because you have to
think i  I position the whole thing
differently than the 6
p.m. sports show now and you have your
well-known five minutes sum up six
minutes summary but
also pack the whole thing more digitally younger
and maybe with one
with fewer blinders than
we’ve seen on the market for some time
present sports is possible you
say yes like john madden reinvented
the nfl moderation or commentary
so to speak is coachee sum so to speak
the german tone matton
yes i have to explain again germain
nancy
was one of the most successful nfl coaches
i think with a huge win rate
so to speak believe  i
play top 100 i think with the
oakland raiders who then became
a
co-moderator relatively early on
and with his
terminology, so to speak, which has also become part of general american usage, so to speak, the way nfl players did on american
television back then  s you
have been commented on the big three networks
reinvented it, so to speak, and
thus created an unbelievable
brand for yourself and i think the
funny
thing is to talk to one because i think he was afraid of flying he is
the recently deceased john lennon and
is then always in  drove his mobile home from
game to game and I think
if you look at the nfl in the
usa the already
metten got a boost, so to speak, and then again
fox as fox, so to speak, as if it will
network has also acquired the rights
again to present the  games
done differently and that you
both look at what someone has given for a
jump in the nfl and
then, to be fair, says the way
prosieben or 1 max presented the
nfl and how a coaching sum
people who maybe not with everyone
rules are 100% familiar, so to speak,
ran differently again and also
with a way like he probably has
one  new young target group, so to speak,
formed a kind of community
there you have to say respect, so
I think it's clear the comparison
is not transferrable one-to-one,
but to say that he introduced a young
target group there to the
nfl and also made commitments  even
though all the rules are 100 percent
understood and there's still a game
for the people who are all in place
, yes, you
summed it up perfectly, of course, it's
not just a coach in the summer, yes,
I think he's done a lot there
just a really likeable guy and
it comes from the field but i think
that shows once again how important talent
is and how important it is to have the
right people
in the right place if
you don't if you don't make it
in a sport like this  like american
football, again and again
, to
explain to the danes how to approach the fans, yes, to make it
easier for them to get started  tern it's all the more difficult
to win new fans for it and the
exciting thing in germany is that yes where
the nfl in the usa is
struggling a bit with it at the moment okay
spectators are getting older in
germany it's exactly the mutual
phenomenon to see that in  in the
last few years, an extremely large number of young people have
noticed that i sometimes ask a question
sorry philipp then you can again
i don't want to monopolize
that the nba has managed
to bind young people to itself in the usa
because ultimately i'd say one of those
influenza culture lives in the
country or just a harem or just
somehow mbit they are all
their own brands, so to speak, and the nfl will
not have pushed so hard with the
exception of tom brady or patrick
mathys of such individual brands
certainly also for the product  60
players and not five the helmet and so
on
and that's a challenge for
the nfl in the usa, so to speak, even more so
this that doing what i know
nothing with the nbl has created in the
end it's similar to winter sports
only if you look at ice hockey if
you look at downhill they all have
a helmet on that means the
faces are football like basketball just
less  present and bigger scott more
people in the team you just have to
memorize and get to
know a lot more names before you can create these people
byrne you have
the lighthouses like now a
tom brady who said after the season
ok after 22 years it's over
doesn't help either yes and that doesn't
help either, of course it helps totally and in that
respect it's perhaps one of the
reasons why you try all the harder to create this
connection between sport and
entertainment because in the end it
's your multipliers, of course,
who get the whole thing out into the world even more
wearing old is then
maybe the
58 players of the squad do as
explained  are you worried that there is
actually an interest in losing weight
among young people in
germany in the usa so is that just a
bit newer or how
exactly does losing weight come about is also totally relative
now yes so you just saw
that it’s like that
the average age
of the
spectators at the super bowl has increased slightly in recent years, for example
why it is like that in the usa yes i mean
i can't answer the exact question now
the brand has simply been
present for decades and by far the
the biggest sports brands are probably
somehow associated with the aging of
society as a whole because where
it’s really exciting the season
in the usa the nfl ratings
have risen relatively sharply yes of
course the play offs were i think apart
from the wild card round or the
first round ultimately  also mega
exciting and sometimes the
qualification through the now 14 places
sometimes  tighter that made the last few
days more exciting and that
actually had an extremely
positive impact on the audience ratings that is
the question of whether the trend that was in the
years before has now been reversed by the nfl in
the usa exactly that
can well be that we  probably
only seen in the last few years but
I find the level of education mentioned very exciting if you were to think
about it today how will it actually build you the
perfect
sports entertainment slash
media product I think you have
now seen a lot in the player
which shows why the nfl
the topic of balance is relatively close, the
topic of tension, so almost every
playoff game was really only decided with
the last kick or the last
touchdown that
outsiders who suddenly this year
in the bangles who suddenly end up in the super bowl are those
yes quite a lot of
ingredients where you say hey that
totally speaks for the fact that there is also a
zeitgeist served where you would you would you
recommend the bundesliga to also go to play-
offs there is the whole
discussion anyway so if you had
missed the play-offs would have done a great
job so i am not in the
position to make the recommendation
and i am  yes, someone who not
only spent a lot of time in football
but who also used to stand in the
curve and since he is a traditionalist
in football i think i would
find it difficult in the bundesliga or in general with the foot of the player but
at the same time it is a huge
challenge  that's why we should the
big organizations in football how
do you manage that not to let the gap keep widening but to
keep
the tension up
but it's not that
the concept is always one end there are clubs here
in germany  and here there are
billionaires as a kind of concept, yes,
every club belongs to media.de, there is no other way
t
who was that the only way or was there
between ways i think the exciting thing
is yes if you look here you are
absolutely right except for the green bay
packers who are a bit in
free float, they are all
mostly family and and many  also
for decades yes so it's not at all
that the
subsidy business is where you say it's different
than in european football there comes
now because they didn't now the sheikh
and bought newcastle united and now
he puts so much money on it and makes them
out of it  nothing at once to
maybe be serious by mail to values
ese are struc
ures that have grown over decades and insofar as th
y go hand in hand with a certain tradition and y
s the exciting thing is that
lot of the money that the clubs belon
to two billionaires but in the end it helps
them yes  not at all
because topics like salary caps, for example,
don't give you a big
competitive advantage competitive advantage
like that  The change is created here again
by the jetpack system by the
balance in the league overall
so that actually almost the question of
who they belong to takes a back seat, but if he just
had two bad years then
by then two years  later with a
good coach suddenly up again because
he drew the first draft
picks no so how is it for you that
you briefly mentioned in the preliminary talk
also had to present that
germany concept in front of a zoom chorus
then with 20 25 billionaires  that
's a bit unusual yes, that's exactly us
that the topic where do we play in
germany now that nothing has
fallen from heaven but of course there are
also the bodies within the nfl that
have to be picked up is
a brothel as a commissioner that
's the international  committee and that
's the way it is, there are a number
of clubs without the glazer family that
also have gels  itet belongs to the
owners of the lows et cetera who sit in there and
then place the topic in the
context of the totally exciting experience
because in the end they have to approve it and
have to say we go with it because
the nfl is ultimately an organization
similar to them  dfl consists of the members
and because
what is planned must be more capable of winning a majority, but do
n't you actually believe that in the
us sports again,
but roger goodell and his
team can influence the product more
than a gentleman seifert used to and now
a woman hops i
always have the feeling that
at the dfl, of course, there are first and second leagues again,
that means the
clubs again with each other, sometimes completely
different incentive systems i
always have the feeling that the dfl is a
bit like that  giant tanker is
very, very difficult
to make ready for change and you can see
that in the entire product  i think
there has been hardly any relevant change in the last ten 15 years,
although the world
around it social media
attention economy new competition
new streaming has totally changed and
to this day there is no
separate streaming product from the dfl
while the nfl  with the gameplay scene
product, a certain clientele was
extremely successful around the world and
you now know that
the dfl also worked for fortuna, so that’s my
impression from the outside, you can confirm it from the
inside, so i think if you
’re on the nrw now, it’s it  so that you
simply have a very homogenous group of people
primarily responsible yes if
you want
to call the owners that way yes we have a similar
background to a large extent in the sense that
they have worked successfully themselves that
in many cases we also come from a somewhat similar
environment  and
I think it does overall  it tends to be
easier for the league
to make bigger decisions yes,
that's the way it has been from the last to
this season for the first time from 16 to
17 regular season games
that's actually a huge
change because all of a sudden you're
just your  make the season longer yes
that has to be negotiated with the players
but if you agree that in a very
homogenous round then it is
easier i think in football overall i
had to say historically influenced
fans just vote a lot much much stronger
and that’s why you have to
vote in a completely different way  choose ways
to push through such changes believes believes
do you believe to
ask this football question again what now had a
few minutes to
think about it
if if you say it
we what would you change now even
if you have you have no
advice but  we can play this
game what if so that became the
dfl k  you also own all clubs
would you own what would you do
now, so to speak, with your experience you
've seen the premier league you've
seen rocket you have the consulting
background you've already seen first
ones from the
nfl there are three things you could say
who you now, so to speak,
without wanting to sound presumptuous, who would like to
throw my pool into the room,
great respect for his tenacity
, I won't give any advice now, so
you have what you want, because it
will be,
so I think, on the one hand, I'll
see that  make the
television broadcasts
even more
entertaining, so to speak, so
that i watch that i may
have more access to interviews to
play so i say that i
emotionalize the product even more
secondly i think in order
to reach the younger target group
i think is the restrictive handling
of rights  especially in germany where
i think the association  n and not even
yourself you don't have to correct
them, they're allowed to, fortune was allowed to share
the goals
themselves via social media in my day because
I don't think the clubs have any
rights in the nfl, every club is allowed to a
certain extent, I think about  twitter
via instagram also share moving pictures
so i think that if you notice that
you are in the young target group
, if you lose the attention game there
, whether it is against the nfl
or against netflix or against amazon
prime tv, i have to ask myself how
i can reach them  Yes, and I have to go
to the channels and I can
say yes, but somehow I gave
sky the rights and thus
I curtailed my own freedom of action
, so somehow point 2
and point 3 I personally would just
say that it is  a platform business
the bundesliga and in all platforms
business as number 23
or four now italy spain
germany m  Al seen none of the
platform survive in the position
not permanently that means either yes
I would just mergin and say I
do a league with the Spanish
French Jenische German league I
have no idea how immonet and immowelt are
deleted and then, so to speak, against
Moscow to a better position  have
and you have to think about that and I
think you're for the super league
without the premium I actually think
the only chance that we would
remain relevant and not just become a
feather league would be a league but
also with up and down we can you
can  imagine somehow seven
german clubs, seven italian,
seven french, seven spanish and
then one of the clubs from each of the
seven keeps moving up and down and
i just want to see that exciting i find
it somehow we always talk about
the european idea and then talk about
it  always so super emotional about
national leagues and i think e  it
would also be in the spirit of the european
idea to do that and it would solve the problem
that in the premier league which is
the leading platform and from
these so-called flywheel effects,
so to speak, more television income best
players best coaches more
attention more attention to
television income that you  because there is
another chance and for that you have to do it
radically and the first two
points, how does the product present itself,
so what has fox done with the nfl, these
are small steps, but i think
it’s back to a certain extent in the
meantime
back on the titanic and i
think you just have to make it big
now he says a lot of normal
things so i think what's up if
that's totally worth considering and also really
honestly you already
think about this coming together in football now
with the holland and belgian league so just
out of weakness they choose so
down that they like others  s were able
to go as sams before you were so down
west german locked out of strength to
get them together my thoughts on
this but another question the nfl has is
incredibly good and i think that in the team what also happens
more often in the podcast that
this shortage well so it works
now, like in the fashion areas,
brand also has ferrari, you can see
that i only sell 10,000 more cars,
they don't make them at all and i think the nfl
understood that very well
,
17 games, you thought about it for a long time,
one more game, one more player
so it's crazy how little it actually
17 games only but 17 game days
then stop the players but in
germany there's far too much football
so it's somehow dfb cup
bundesliga international business of the
national team also configuration
head which is way too much and
think that  i manage this shortage so in
the end a bit of a manager
or have to the colleagues in the usa die
have to manage shortages yes i think
it's an extremely important point because
you don't even have to look so much at
football but you can look
at other sports yourself in the usa
baseball 100 what is it 130
season play 1962 862 basketball
82 years that  is already with its not
perfect the shortage
can work is crazy so it
actually one of the whiskeys that you
say
17 games and what i just said again
that was a long
discussion now to 17 or that one to
add and then but also  to be in the
position where every game counts yes
i think the challenge for so
who buys a
season ticket now if you know you can or
had to go 130 x 160 x now you say
every game counts again then
the playoffs in germany will work
not bad at all so players are
abstractly speaking i think it's a
great thing yes i think i'm
kind of beautiful and  that is of course
this moment of tension, which in
any case also
contributes to the fact that, for example, the
tv response in Germany has
been extremely positive again in the last few months
because you see what this moment is going to be like
at the end of the last minute
and
the touch  there has to be thrown or
not what that was again
quality for a tv man that was
to speak economically he had by
far the most successful
league in the world what makes your ports
total turnover so as a group as a
whole I can't say at all now
so the most important thing is the  tv
contract you have to say that's where
most of the money comes from, it was concluded last
year, it leads
for eleven years, I think that's 110
billion dollars, 410 billion, so in
one year
over 10 billion will come completely,
but that's exactly what the domestic
contract
in addition station so what all huge
and tradition without gamepad
so that's pron  I domestic free and you also have
the games in the USA again with
the red, so to speak, which now, for example,
in Germany on the son runs in English
, among other things,
the point is that is big is huge
and that's even though the
product actually offers very little  because you
would think that the
baseball league with more teams and more
games is actually much more valuable,
or the basketball league, but that's the
case  maybe it won't get better
if more just gets better if it
just gets less it's amazing that he
exactly and i think total sales
with 15 billion you can also see that
the majority of life comes from the
tv and that shows again it is
an entertainment product that is also
geared towards the tv side,
otherwise the broadcasters would not be
willing to pay that much and he has  to
that point i think there is
a best case example yes where you see
scarcity works you see that
people are also
willing to take on a
lot of hardship and maybe also dig deeper into their pockets
if they know that's it
is simply rarer
with the tv rights in the usa, the broadcasters
even tend to pay more than
they earn and why are they doing this because they are
then within the scope of the nfl
but the last camp before tv event
in the usa are able to do their
rest of the program  to promote and,
so to speak, to bind customers to
ultimately linear television again
, so to speak, that was
also what rupert murdoch realized when he ultimately bought the nfl rights
with fox, the fourth network, which
was relatively irrelevant at the time,
so to speak, and said to
get one year  so i
would still reach local stations and
i get relevance and
that led to the thinking  nfl is also very
well able
to monetize it via freetv in the usa because
they still have these campfires and
so, so to speak, perfectly conveys the value of the television stations to
itself,
is it actually
that the game is in germany or the
games in  england should also be made
aware to have another window
on american television that
i think that the time
difference will be played early in the morning in the usa and
its like 9 and 10 o'clock there are
no games made in the usa because it's too
early you're up  once then day
modern morning noon and afternoon
or evening players don't have a new
training window is now also in the
calculation of typing that doesn't matter so
depending on where you have been in the usa
usa then sometimes even has a negative
impact yes if you're now on the
west coast  are and you play in
Germany at lunchtime then that is
also still to be remembered but basically
clear I mean the n  Of course it's also
exciting to
think about the time window in which she plays on
Monday evening, Saturday evening, Sunday evening
in England. So far, I think the players have
always been around 3 p.m. English time to 4
p.m. German time, so about three
hours before the normal start at 7 p.m.
on Sunday evening, that's the same for Munich
again a time that
is being considered sunday 4 p.m.
the whole thing will, so to speak, take that in
terms of the
schedule as far as the scheduling is concerned that will come in the
course of spring sven does
n’t have to be patient a bit you say in the
end you will also talk to tom brady
when  he's coming back from retirement, so to speak,
to celebrate his comeback in munich
that would definitely be a
story, we'll have to wait and see whether it comes to that
,
philipp might go back to your
point about internationalization at
that, i think
that's what's what now, in the end  my job is
it's already in england and in the team there is
mexico canada c  hina
i find it exciting and then
also a bit different
from other sports that the
league
doesn't just look at the dollars
in the first step, but in the first step really at
fan growth yes knows a bit
what you were  you have to do it
then you are really measured by
it to look or what to say
what do you have to do about the americans in the aks
also with jobs again one who is
certainly not badly paid
so what has to about what would have to be
measured
yes exactly the things yes well
how is the fan base developing in
germany how is our
clearly developing together with the team in england
how is the
media product developing overall how
are consumer products developing so
saving merchandising is a very big
topic so you have to report it
maybe you can add it again  the ea
title where you can play american football
those are the things j  a
how does a digital reach develop
all the things we want to
bring forward and want to grow up and
differences in the
contract it doesn’t say so in the contract but of
course in the end people look at
it and say have we
developed further or not them
conspiracy theorists they have
already said mr seifert is changing to
springer mrs hopfen is changing
to the dfl via bcg, so to speak, and now they have it
again you used to be with bcg
and then it was
a bit like that with fortuna the dfl is now changing to the
nfl and  next year the rights have to be
granted and then they will go
to the combo seifert and springer, so to speak,
we have extremely good connections there
, our current media partners
and they will of course continue to be
the first contact people what
we see and i don’t think that’s a
secret either  due to the success
in recent years, the interest
in every fa  there will be a lot of people
knocking on the door and saying hey how does it look
then the rights will run out can
we talk but yes
we just talked about it we are totally
satisfied with our current
partners and in this respect our first
connections are his personal consequences
so my class funds run
like the station but quickly listed at the
end is for diameter is also a
sign more attractive now to be nfl
managing director in germany
than at a german bundesliga
club finds sitting on the board or
keeping the pulse to bertelsmann is
you can probably do that  better paid
so whether that's more attractive now i
think that a subject is also a subject
your questions there are many people who
would have said my big dream is
to work in football and i also
liked working
there it's easy for me personally  a
very exciting moment where you see
you have in the last year  en already
had good growth and now you have
the opportunity for the first time to become
even more active on German soil
and to see how far
you can actually bring this
sport to Germany because in the
end you had to say it’s not a sport
which most Germans grew
up with but a lot of traction in the
day care centers for the schools
really wanted to say it was a task to plant it
as a sport on a broad basis or is it
just about the nfl the few coalition
security moments or do you
really want to work with schools now too  talk
and then somehow bring football into the
curriculum and so an extremely
good question because for us the
approach is not to say we’ll come
to Germany with a game and yes the
whole circus will fly a day or two
later it’s off again but
for us, it's about getting
activation and growth all year round
and that's why, on the one hand, when we talked to the
cities, it was
also about what we can do
together, what goes beyond the day of the game,
that would be we doing in Frankfurt, that
would be doing in Munich, that we will
also do in Düsseldorf and after the
games exactly  such topics play a
role, yes, how do you get
more people to play and that will be
flag football as a first step, which
also supports the nfl financially because if
you talk about it, yes, why does it get
ripped out without text, i.e. flags in the belt
or with boys
children play don't get hurt
exactly exactly so he himself is that the
poor contacts the poor contacts variant
of american football because when
you talk about it yes and talk about strategies
like how can you create fan growth
then of course you can
try things in the short term that's
a game like that  where I think you just
generated significantly more
media attention but a  On the one hand, the
long-term hypothesis is to
get more people to play here
because the kids who played also
have a greater affinity for sport and,
on the other hand, the question of how do you get
more German faces into the leagues
isn’t football myself
been a player never played
myself all the rules one asked
so you are a rule can i be
yes there are so many rules that
i wouldn't presume to know all of them i
think i could watch the game now
and probably would except
for maybe  one or the other
exceptions know all the rules but yes
if somehow a really
crazy flag breaks again but if you
say coach explains what you are currently doing in terms of
formations on the
pitch then you will learn something of course i can
learn a lot from him yes  I think
that's the nice thing about
american football, that you're
actually a bit lean
back can enjoy are more of a
bit the entertainment approach drives
and seeds nice tv recordings good
media product and halftime occurs
after one or you get
really deep because at least
in my opinion there is no
sport really that long and that deep
can deal with simply because the
tactical
finesse there are so diverse
are not the largest and
most relevant brand partners nfl here in the
usa knows what is going on so there are
different pepsi major partners
on hotels marriott touring yes so what
is in germany  if you
listen to someone here he has
budgets and says okay it seems
better you can't even do something
new i want to be there and what do
you have to do and about how
could you even do what we would like to
do  for the possibility to be there
so prices are not yet
defined what is clear we
want and see you there or  they want that
positioned and also see us as a
premium product that is a one game
that will be available every year and
which also has a corresponding
corresponding premium
character in addition to the year-round
activation and what kind of areas
are there in the end you can see even if you
look to london there are of course
ready for the game you have to
hold on to that especially for the nfl
the european games are the
only ones that actually have digital
gangs that means you can play
a message from germany about
the gang to the usa in  the
american households because if
you look at your field game in the usa
it's more or less in your studies
at least free of advertising we have
alex together i already
told you that the machines are a great team to
tokyo and now beijing is sending things on well
maybe we can do it  it's still
that's somehow the is machine
seeker player in munich will yes yes  I
look forward to it when I always listen to
a podcast that you are successful that's
why you're in the
second German league
but is that the other question I
always do here in the podcast I'm
out there looking for personal marketing
for machines now of course I'm looking for a
lot of listeners  then of course
nfl is super exciting and now for the first
time in germany managing director so
the question will you build the team and
if so where or is it ultimately
all remote or working from home so
yes we will build a team, that’s
how we are now  in the very early
stages and yes we will also
open an office in düsseldorf i
think if we had gone with a
city now for four years
a city which was also the original
plan then it would have been
easier where we would have opened the office  now
with two cities it's another
discussion that we'll have internally
because in the end it'll work out  of course on the one
hand yes where will the games take place
but also where do you already have existing
american football structures where are
your advertising partners where are your
media partners so that has
n’t been decided yet at the beginning especially in the
first year we will get a lot of dax from the recession in
munich prosiebensat1 in munich
-corporations in munich the first game
in munich munich
so you have to be honest even
if we look at our numbers there are
most american football fans and
active ones in the west yes there you
have the history too that was just said
with rhein fire frankfurt  galaxy the
associations are there are good reasons
for everyone from hamburg because there is so little presence
in the whole thing for the
processes originally started with nine
cities, nine cities that
expressed their interest and
then the three made it to the final
but did  you honestly don't want to read about it
because that was before
my time in hamburg  yes
we talked to berlins, stuttgart
was there i think hamburg was
there too in the end yes it was just a matter of looking
where is the overall package best
where do we think we
can create the greatest impact and those were the
three cities that made it to the final  come
what what do you do with such a game in
germany in terms of sales what comes
out of it that means if you like a
startup sony has what is
planned now and we just
thought about it a bit personally last night
we appreciate that  do you have to be at 50
million that's really crazy
i can't tell you yet yes
i don't know yet if i keep counting here
and you don't just
keep doing it and philipp says whether you don't
or not nothing so the allianz arena in
munich  I think it has about
7000 business seats and box space
if we now average 1000 euros
for such a business seat and box space
next to windows 7 mi  million euros
then there are still about 60,000
other tickets probably an
average price of 150 euros that if
you add another 9 million that means
ticketing revenue this march
tax about 16
that was a short nod then of course
somehow clear the television revenue is
not additive overall the negotiated
correct there is already no
extra income or
the tv people players there is no
extra of course an extra
income and then you have the advertising income and
what do such verbal things bring in england
to have a comparison i can
i can unfortunately tell you right now  not to
say would do a bad job right away
if you are out of the game
in advertising banner marketing and suburbs
that you are not able to get a few million out of
it so this can
ticketing and advertising if we say 20
million is in the management contract, so to speak,
than if that  for
the bonus of the can so
not at all 50,000 less yes you do
n't have to look when you say there are ten
million dollars tv revenue about
200 believe what 285 games season and
play offs about that means we have
about 35 million us dollars if
i now play all of them
distribute it right away that's of course adding 20
million euros to it you're
about 50 million
euros that means you're paying you're the ceo of a
decent medium-sized company that
means first of all congratulations on your
arithmetic skills
yes actually what i can say is
that we're at the end
just coming to germany at the beginning
and not saying we have to generate the maximum profit here now, on
the contrary, we say we
want to invest yes, so we want to
see how do we manage to do it with the
money plan and with his game
you earn money but how  can we manage
to push the sport as a whole with the money that is earned there and
he here I mean digi  tal thought a bit
yes you try he first
to create a range before you about the
next steps that means already
planning which influenza then somehow in the
fall a munich advantage that he
while many german fans
can be happy then it goes to
munich  posted on the way i would
say it's the left ones in
alexander's box first the tickets should probably go
to the people who want the jobs
and all good things come in threes the
influenza would apply was this number
the teams want that you get three
employees for your  linking inbox
it's not that bad but
actually it's already the case that we work
very closely with influenza so the topic is the
super bowl yes heidi
klum will now be present on sunday be
it for the older target group or
he deliberately brings people out  germany
or germany who here after so that
i here the rich will
send into germany exactly because  I
mean in the end the topic so
everything we think about and everything
we discussed
actually comes back to a question how
do we manage not to have any growth
in Germany and there are
different approaches yes topic getting people
to play topic  to reach people via tv
but also how do you use
digital in the best possible way and of
course you quickly get to the topic in
friends something is the platform and
the hardest currency for
growth it is the audience ratings it is the
readers followers on instagram it is the
subscribers  with gamepad what is there
now the the core currency there is
not one core currency but is
actually the things
you just touched on plus consumer
products are so how many people
then end up buying the costs so what exactly is the
nice thing when  you now out on germany
that's why germany will always be the
number one growth market worldwide
according to the nfl  are you already rubbed in
germany with actually all or with
most of the relevant topic with madden ea
with merchandising sales with gamepad
you are either number one worldwide after the
usa or number two how can
that be explained so quickly
comparatively no now so affine
estonia he exactly how  it explains itself that
's a good question i think there are
different reasons one is
that you of course have a certain history
yes there used to be nfl
europe we also talked to racing driver frankfurt
galaxy in the 90s a
lot of people just sort of
did  access to breaking football,
at least in some cities of in the
end it was almost just a german
league and next to it in the last few years
the young generation to the next
brand even mexico or something is
not as big as germany so
it always depends  when you
look at koks, for example, you know how many
social media followers you had is there
i think mexico in some dimensions
ahead of germany yes, but if you
look at the sales and if you
look at the kps we just
mentioned,
germany is number one in most topics after where it's
actually only missing if you look at the formula  1
looks like michael schumacher so a
german quarterback who is really
with germans so now there are already
a number of players who are
partly successful but just not so
present and the prepositions they
play are not so present but
german quarterback is show what  i
think there is alex honey or something like that
there are already a couple of german colossuses in the knockout
system is that foreseeable yes well that
would of course be the big dream you saw
it with dirk nowitzki yes
how much it pulls and how much it
pushes me  i think in germany there
are still a number of dallas
mavericks fans who were simply
guided by dirk nowitzki it's like that
that you can't force
it and that's of course more difficult
because in Germany the game is simply
less widespread than in
the USA, for example, but
I find that exciting again there
when you think about what makes the
league the league extremely active  so there
is something called the international
password program where people consciously look at
which players in american football
youngsters in other countries
might have the potential of skills
at someday
i would have heard about this alex
the coach i'm looking for  the time he told me
that somehow political life
was quite relevant to be
pushed out and to but ca
n't assess exactly whether that can
ever be done what are you have you there
people in view can
do it so i can do it i can do it too  not of
course 100% classified but you can
already see that you are also in this
international player password  program
there it is so that yes you can too, for
example as an athlete yes if
you have the appropriate skills
you could take part in it there is
this combine yes where you can take the
step into the training sports
of the options and there are always
German athletes there because it's
also something that the league
wants to consciously push more German
faces because even when you talk to people in the nfl
they all say hey that would be
great if we weren't just in jakob
johnson or amon rastan brown or ikz
herrn  brown in the nfl but
if we were best to get a
star quarterback out of banknotes but
for that i think you have to get him to american high school and an american college very, very
early on
because the position that an
athlete can do in the end holds it
are dominant very early on in the storm where
did the
reading of the moves as a quarterback go or in the end
what the defensive  it's just
unbelievable
that you have to be trained, so to speak, because you have
to recognize that very quickly, you have to
react to it and you can't cover
that as well in this international program as you can
now, perhaps, with a
position in the total special team and
that's why he's the one himself
the most obvious pole position is the kicker,
you can maybe convert from football
and quarterback
is probably the technical
position and where you need exactly that if
experience and that's
definitely good if you go to good
high schools and good universities  Were they
the ones who put exactly that in the
foreground ok so I think
that I have all the questions to us but voted
all questions closed we have
tried to get as many as possible
out of the we are looking forward to
the game now when the park comes
out tonight that  is somehow
on sunday evening and wants to hear then
it starts again in
september  But the power of the new season is
then and then the game is there and
you're in your heart who doesn't know exactly
towards the end of the year the exact
scheduling will probably follow when
the NFL game plan is announced
but that's also what's going on with the teams
what has to be coordinated with the league et cetera
so
we still have to get tickets from time to time if you
want to register what is the name of the
page you can register
mfg.com / munich you are welcome to register and
then the ticketing then
logically runs via ticketmaster
again  the usa is there we are
still in the process of looking at which
solution works best for germany
but ticketmaster is
some listeners don't think i know it at all
philipp is on the supervisory board
at cts eventim ag and so the happy
ending according to the people  the podcast here,
so to speak, if we talk again about the
ticketing rights here on a small scale,
so what we need is what we need
there is definitely a stable
server because the hat caught fire
the ticketing for the olympics is so
that's not a problem at
all all right alex thank you so much if you're at the
start then logically
we have a whole
bunch of german guests  there are also
representatives from the bundesliga from bayern
münchen on site,
this also there exactly also from bayern the
american even he doesn’t come anymore
we via other club representatives there and
then we have a few guests
we already have influence over it
but a driver so she has  clubs then
there if you're a singer from Revolverheld
fitness influenza that's a whole series and
it's an ideal one we represent there
and have already been to the party
that's a nice certain beekeeper johannes
strate so if that's a fun party
you just named her
ok  so say a lot that you have us here,
so to speak, a god has him as a
media center here very impressive
but i already had some  how
did you actually experience the
elbphilharmonie and many many and the
emergency room it's something like this again
really cool
thank you thank you thank you very much this podcast is produced by popstars
at mr